Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 150. Das ist ja schon ein kleines Jubiläum hier, hier wo immer so viel gesprochen wird und besprochen wird und umschrieben wird und überhaupt versucht wird zu erfühlen, was es denn so an Wissen zu vermitteln gibt. Und da dachte ich mir, da müsste man doch vielleicht auch einfach mal zu so einer Sendung auch mal ein bisschen über das Sprechen reden. Aber ich will jetzt nicht einfach nur dahersülzen über Podcasting und was nicht noch alles, sondern wie es hier Usus und die Regel und die Normalität ist, gibt es einen interessanten Gast mit einem interessanten Thema. Und ich begrüße Trilli. Hallo Trilli.
Freut mich, freut mich.
Worüber wollen wir reden? Wir wollen über das reden, was du eigentlich so machst. Und du bist ja auch im Sprecher-Business und beschäftigst dich aber mit, ja, wie sagt man so schön, Dubbing oder im Deutschen eher Synchronisation, Filmsynchronisation, sprich das Nachsprechen von Filmen. Das ist ja eigentlich etwas, was so ein bisschen einen schlechten Ruf hat. Also in Deutschland auf jeden Fall. Also ich gucke mir sehr ungern übersetzte Filme an.
Ich auch.
Das ist ja schon mal die beste Voraussetzung.
Ja, ich versuche das auch möglichst zu vermeiden, übersetzte Filme anzugucken, weil ich nicht mal ganz glücklich bin mit dem Dubbing, was so gemacht wird.
Also das ist jetzt aber eher so dieses professionelle Problem, dass wenn man irgendwie die Sachen kennt, dass man dann immer erschaudert und erzittert, wenn es nicht perfekt ist.
Glaube ich nicht mal, ich glaube, jeder hat so seine schlechten Erfahrungen mit dem Dubbing schon gemacht, dass man irgendeinen Film mal umgeschaltet hat, oder man hat ein Stück im Original gesehen und ein Stück gedubbt und erschreckt den Fernseher ausgeschaltet oder so. Ich glaube, da hat jeder seine schlechten Erfahrungen schon gemacht. Das Dubbing hat einen schlechten Ruf und ich glaube auch zurecht.
Aber auch gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Das ist immer so interessant, womit man eigentlich gerade so geprägt wurde. Es gibt so die Fernsehserien, die man so in seiner Jugend geschaut hat. Selbst wenn man dann so ein notorischer Original-Film-Gucker geworden ist, die kriegt man dann irgendwie im Original gar nicht mehr so richtig rein. Also wenn man da einmal drauf hängen geblieben ist, auf der Stimme dann auch, dann ist es irgendwie total schwierig. Magnum ist auch immer ein beliebiges Beispiel, von mir zumindest rauszunehmen. Da habe ich einfach auch so bestimmte Formulierungen so drin. Ich weiß, was sie jetzt sagen wollen und sie haben Recht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das im Original ist, aber ich will es auch gar nicht hören. Das bringt es dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man dann erstmal Filme im Original oder auch Fernsehserien, also ich glaube bei Fernsehserien ist das sogar noch ein bisschen extremer, weil man da einfach viel mehr, weil man einfach so lange Zeit damit verbringt und noch sehr viel mehr mit den Stimmen und damit eben natürlich auch mit den Charakteren so bondet, da geht dann irgendwie auch gar kein Weg mehr zurück.
Das ist eine Erziehungssache. Es ist von Land zu Land verschieden. Es gibt in jedem Land ein anderes Dubbing zum Beispiel, eine andere Art von Dubbing und eine andere Art das zu machen. Man kann sich wirklich an alles gewöhnen. Zum Beispiel in Polen, da wird nicht richtig gedubbt auf die Lippen, sondern da spricht ein Sprecher, der spricht alle Schauspieler oben drüber.
Stimmt, das hab ich ja auch schon mal gehört.
Eine Frau und ein Mann, die unterhalten sich und oben drüber spricht einer, der macht so wie ein Reporter, spricht er oben drauf den Text. Wie ein Simultan-Übersetzer oder so. Man kann sich wirklich an alles gewöhnen. In jedem Land gibt es eine andere Prägung, wie das gemacht wird.
Das heißt, das wird da so generell so gemacht?
Ja, alles. Das ganze Fernsehen ist so, du hörst einen Sprecher oder, mit Glück hast du mal zwei, eine Frau und ein Mann, die sprechen einfach oben drauf. Das Original wird dann leise gemacht und oben drauf spricht der Sprecher und dann aber auch nicht lippensynchron? Nein, auch nicht lippensynchron und auch nicht mit dem Ausdruck, wie das die Schauspieler machen, sondern so, der lässt sich so ein bisschen mitnehmen, aber der Schauspieler nicht, wie ein Simultanübersetzer oder so.
Oh nein, bring mich nicht um.
Genau, und dann macht er die Stimme so ein bisschen kleiner und spricht die Frau auch. Also man kann sich echt an alles gewöhnen. Wir sind einfach an das deutsche Dubbing gewöhnt, wie das so ist.
Wobei da kann ich mich auch nur sehr eingeschränkt dran gewöhnen. Aber wie gesagt, da gibt es auch positive und negative Beispiele. Noch schlimmer finde ich eigentlich das deutsche Original. Wo ich komplett sterbe, das sind so deutsche Fernsehserien, wo sie dann einfach sowieso schon so reden. Da läuft mir mittlerweile ein kalter Schauer in den Rücken. Deutsche Fernsehserien kann ich mir einfach nicht anschauen. Und zwar vollkommen egal, worum es geht. Ich bin generell einfach schockiert. Woran ich das? Das ist irgendwie so eine ganz merkwürdige Diktion, die davor herrscht.
Das hat so was Steriles, finde ich, so was Lebloses. Ich kann es auch nicht sehen.
Ja, so Lindenstraße und so weiter, das ist doch, genau, das wirkt doch wie erschossen.
Ja, das ist so Video, erst mal diese Video-Optik auch, weil das wird, glaube ich, dann auch mit Video gedreht. Das ist nicht Film, sondern das ist so Videokamera.
Ja, keine Weite, keine Perspektive, immer nur so frontal drauf, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, Thema Dubbing.
Ja, ich meine, du hast ja schon jetzt angesprochen, es gibt halt so Länderkulturen. Also in welchen Kulturen ist denn sozusagen jetzt Filmsynchronisation Usus und wo nicht?
Es gibt Länder, wo gar nicht synchronisiert wird, zum Beispiel auch. Die von vornherein, wo alles, also außer Kindergeschichten, die Kinder können nicht so schnell die Untertitel lesen, aber es gibt Länder, viele in Südamerika zum Beispiel, wo überhaupt nicht gedappt wird, in Holland, wo gar nicht gedappt wird, die gucken alles im Original an.
Deswegen können die auch alle so gut Englisch. Und Skandinavien auch, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Soweit ich weiß. Es sind ja auch diese Länder, wo einfach so wenig Leute diese Sprache sprechen, dass der Markt auch zu klein ist, dass es sich droht.
Ich arbeite in Katalonien und Katalonien hat ein paar Millionen Einwohner. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie viele. Weniger als zehn, glaube ich. Und da wird alles geduppt. Die Kinofilme, alles wird für diese kleine Bevölkerung geduppt.
Also Katalonien in Spanien, also die Region Barcelona, die ja nicht Spanisch spricht im Wesentlichen.
Die haben ihr eigenes Kino auf Katalan und ihre Fernsehsender auf Katalan und die Filme werden ins Katalonische geduppt. Also es hängt nicht unbedingt von der Anzahl der Leute ab, die da wohnen, sondern so, wie sehr die Leute ihre Sprache so beschützen wollten, glaube ich. Zum Beispiel ist Katalonien ja ganz krass, nachdem Franco das so lange unterdrückt hatte, dass sie ihre eigene Sprache nicht sprechen durften und die Schule alles nicht in ihrer Sprache war, sind die halt ins Gegenteil umgeschlagen. Jetzt gibt es sozusagen so eine gesetzliche Rate, wo vorgeschrieben ist, wie viele Filme in Katalan sein müssen.
Also auch, wenn sie nicht, also die jetzt aus Katalonien kommen müssen oder die übersetzt werden müssen?
Die übersetzt werden müssen. Die Kinos müssen irgendwie, glaube ich, drei Viertel jetzt auf Katalanisch zeigen. Also ist das nicht unbedingt, wenn die unbedingt mit der Größe des Landes zusammen oder so.
Okay, sondern eher damit, wie offen man da ist.
Genau wo das historisch jetzt herkommt, da will ich mich lieber nicht festlegen.
Wobei ich mir da gar nicht so sicher bin, was da eigentlich schlimmer ist, was invasiver ist. Dass ich sozusagen das Fremde, in Anführungsstrichen, mit meiner eigenen Sache dann vertone und damit eigentlich kulturell viel näher an mich heranlasse, mal jetzt andersrum gedacht. Anstatt dass man eben sagt, okay, das ist irgendwie jetzt nicht unseres, da gönnen wir uns maximal Untertitel. Also weiter lassen wir das nicht an uns heran.
Das ist auch immer die große Diskussion beim Dabbing. Selbst beim Dabbing selbst hast du zwei Alternativen. Du platzierst den Film nach Deutschland und übersetzt alle die kulturellen Referenzen. Die reden von so einer Geschirrmarke, die in Amerika total berühmt ist. Du übersetzt die dann und machst daraus Rosenthal-Geschirr. Oder was weiß ich. Also darf man nicht bei Namen von Marken, darf man eh nicht benutzen. Ist ja egal, nur als Beispiel. Du liest das Ding nach Deutschland oder du lässt es im Ausland und übersetzt nur mit dem Ziel, damit die Leute die Sprache besser verstehen. Und das ist die ewige Diskussion, wie man das dann jetzt eigentlich machen sollte.
Das ist auch wichtig, um Witze und Anspielungen zu verstehen auch. Genau.
Also man könnte wirklich die Filme total nach Deutschland verlegen. Du könntest die Straßen, du könntest die Namen ändern. Man könnte das machen, aber da ist glaube ich die Diskussion auch noch nicht zu Ende. Aber es ist der Gang und Gebe, es ist eigentlich nach Deutschland zu verlegen.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal ein bisschen zurückspulen und kurz nochmal drauf eingehen, was eigentlich so dein Werdegang ist und was du da jetzt eigentlich konkret tust. Also du bist ja eigentlich so vom Herzen bis hier Musik geritten, oder?
Kann man so sagen, auf jeden Fall. Obwohl mein Herz jetzt sehr weit ist, habe ich auch noch mit reingenommen. Ich habe eigentlich mich 10 Jahre oder länger nur der Musik gewidmet. 2002, 2003 ging gar nichts mehr, weil wirklich der tote Punkt erreicht, wo man kein Geld mehr mit der Musik machen konnte. Also ich persönlich nicht mehr. Und habe dann mich nachher aus anderem umgeschaut, was auch irgendwie mit Ton zu tun hat und mit Sprache und irgendwie auch kreativ ist, habe mich dann als Sekretärin beworben. Ich glaube nicht an Zufälle, aber ich bin dann sehr direkt in diesem Dubbing-Studio gelandet, was auch der einzige Punkt war, was zusammenbringt, was mir wirklich Spaß macht. Und zwar Ton, also alles im weitesten Sinne. Audio, genau. Zusammen mit Sprachen fand ich schon immer toll.
Genau, du bist ja viel Sprachler.
Genau, ich spreche sechs Sprachen.
Sechs sind es sogar.
Mehr oder weniger gut. Ja, Deutsch und Spanisch natürlich.
Vor allem?
Fließend so. Englisch, Französisch, Portugiesisch und Katalan auch. Klar, Katalan ist eine eigene Sprache, ist wie Holländisch und Deutsch. Katalan und Spanisch zueinander. Genau, und ich war mir aber nicht im Klaren, dass es wirklich einen Beruf gibt, der das zusammenbringt. Dieses Spiel mit der Sprache und mit der Gruppe den Kulturen und das Spiel mit dem mit den Schallwellen.
Und dann bist du in diesem Laden gelandet, der halt Filmsynchronisation macht.
Genau, und das ist ziemlich besonders das Studio, weil die eben nicht nur mit einer Sprache arbeiten, wie das sogar gut gäbe, sondern mit sechs Sprachen. Moment. Also Spanisch machen wir, Italienisch, Französisch, Englisch, Deutsch und Katalan. Ja, sechs Sprachen auch. Das heißt, wir haben ein großes Produktionsbüro, wo von jeder dieser Sprachen Leute vertreten sind, die die Projekte beaufsichtigen. Und dann haben wir viele Studios, wo dann die ganzen verschieden-sprachigen Sprecher reinkommen, so den Tag über. Und wir setzen, also synchronisieren hauptsächlich englischsprachige Filme in alle möglichen Sprachen. Also nicht nur englischsprachige, sondern auch viele spanische, viele Produktionen, die da gemacht werden. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen Schritt, der heißt Präproduktion. Bei einer Animation zum Beispiel nimmt man erstmal alles mit einer Stimme auf. Einer spricht die ganzen Texte, die die ganzen Figuren sprechen müssen, und darauf wird es animiert. Ich spreche die ganzen Texte, dann schicken wir dem Studio das zurück und die animieren auf diese Sprache dann die Münder von den Zeichentrickfiguren.
Ach, die Zeichentrickfilme werden dann noch oft die Sprache angepasst?
Ernsthaft?
Nicht alle. Es muss man darauf achten. Es gibt natürlich welche, die machen nur den Mund auf und zu, wie ein Müllschlucker. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Es gibt aber auch Animationen, die sehr viel filigraner sind und die auch, wo man auch erkennen kann, ob deine O oder ein A sagt oder... Und da wird erst die Sprache aufgenommen. Also man hat die Zeichentrickfiguren, du siehst die schon auf dem Bild, aber die haben noch keinen Mund oder nur einen provisorischen Mund. Und dann nimmst du die Sprache auf und darauf wird dann wirklich die Animation fertiggestellt und dann dabst du es nochmal oben drauf mit dem richtigen Ausdruck.
Und gilt das jetzt auch für so mega aufwändige Sachen? Woran muss ich jetzt gerade denken? Ja, ich dachte jetzt hier gerade so an Pixar. Wie heißt denn auch gleich dieser Film mit der Maus? Na, mit der Ratte, mit der Koch. Ratatouille.
Habe ich ja nicht gesehen.
Hast du nicht gesehen, ja okay.
Aber ganz sicher bei solchen Sachen. Die Pixar-Sachen. Die aufwendige Produktion.
Das heißt, wenn der Film in Deutschland im Kino läuft, dann zeigt er im Detail ein anderes Bild, nämlich andere Bewegungsminder?
Nein, die Originalversion ist bestimmt englisch, und dann, wenn man die Übersetzung macht, und das Synchrombuch schreibt, muss man halt die Lippenbewegung berücksichtigen, wie bei einem richtigen Spielfilm. Es gibt ja zwei Schritte, es gibt die Übersetzung und dann das Synchrombuch, und das ist bei solchen Zeichentrick-Animationen dann genauso.
Aber sagst du nicht gerade, der Zeichentrick-Film wird angepasst auf die Synchronisation?
Ja, aber nur in der Originalversion. Es gibt eine Originalversion, die erste, bei der Englischen, die ist meistens Englisch.
Okay, gut, jetzt verlege ich langsam. Ich dachte jetzt schon, es gibt dann für jede Sprachvariante...
Könnte man machen, theoretisch, aber...
Bevor wir da weitermachen, deine Aufgabe ist sozusagen, eine vollständige Synchronisationsproduktion durchzuführen. Das ist eigentlich das, was du machst, für Deutsch.
Ja, bei uns ist das ein bisschen anders in Spanien als hier in Deutschland. Also was ich jetzt erzähle, wie wir arbeiten, das ist nicht gang und gäbe in Deutschland.
Genau.
Bei uns ist es aber, also ich, mein Posten nennt sich offiziell Projektmanagerin. Das heißt, ich bin für das Projekt halt verantwortlich. Ich kriege den Film zugeschickt, ich gucke mir den an, ich entscheide, wie das sein, wie das gemacht werden sollte, wie sich das anhören soll am Ende. Also ich habe sozusagen die Vorstellung davon, wie das Endprodukt sein soll. Und versuche das dann so zu leiten, dass es so rauskommt am Ende auch. Und je nachdem, manchmal fühle ich auch Regie. Ich fühle oft Regie auch. Manchmal schreibe ich auch Synchrom-Bücher. Aber dieser Vielfalt von Aufgaben, das kann ich nicht nur machen, weil ich da bin in Spanien. Weil das unbürokratischer ist als hier. Unbürokratischer auch, weil wir im Ausland sind und nicht, weil wir deutsche Synchronisationen im Ausland machen. Die Spanier ist jetzt auch wieder anders, aber da wir im Ausland sind, sind wir so ein bisschen vogelfrei irgendwie arbeiten, wie es uns gefällt.
Aber die spanische Abteilung ist dann bürokratischer oder was? Es ist einfach generell unbürokratischer als in Deutschland.
Nee, die spanische ist dann doch wieder bürokratischer, weil es gibt ja zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie Gewerkschaften für die Sprecher und so, die so gewisse Prozederes festlegen, wie das gemacht werden muss. Und die gibt es für Spanier natürlich auch. Die sind nicht so streng wie in Deutschland, aber die gibt es auch, weil wir nicht in Deutschland sind und auch nicht Spanisch machen, greift keiner von beiden auf uns zu.
Verstehe. Okay, ihr seid da die Enfants terribler. Gut, also du bist die Projektmanagerin. Das heißt, irgendein Mensch hat einen Film gemacht und entscheidet dann, den bräuchten wir jetzt auch mal. Also der ist dann nicht auf Deutsch. Und es gibt auch die Entscheidung, was ist sozusagen Ursache dafür, dass... Also klar.
Wie die Ursache.
Ja, okay, also auf der einen Seite die Länder sind, wenn man den Film da halt zeigen will, klar, die Kultur erfordert halt eine Synchronisation. Ich hatte irgendwie beim anderen Gespräch so ein bisschen rausgehört, wenn irgendwie aber jetzt jemand sich für eine Filmförderung zum Beispiel beantragt, dann muss der dann auch von vornherein bestimmte Synchronisationen auch zusagen, unabhängig davon, ob der Film jemals erfolgreich gewesen ist, gewesen sein wird oder nicht.
Da kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus, aber ich weiß, wenn man eine Filmförderung kriegt, zum Beispiel in Deutschland, dann muss, die Filmförderung ist ja im Grunde eine Industrieförderung. Es geht ja nicht darum, wirklich den Film zu fördern, sondern dass diese Industrie gefördert wird, die sich um die Filmerei rum bewegt. Deswegen kannst du damit nicht ins Ausland gehen, sondern musst das Dubbing dann in Deutschland machen.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, der soll dann irgendwie synchronisiert werden?
Was steht dann bei euch auf? Jemand hat einen Film produziert, der findet dann dafür einen Vertrieb in irgendeinem Land, und dann kümmert sich der Vertrieb normalerweise darum, dass der Film gedubbt wird. Dann macht man einen Preis aus, klare Sache. Wenn der Preis abgesegnet ist, kriegen wir das Material. Wir bekommen den Originalfilm. Wir bekommen die Musik- und Effektespur.
In welcher Form bekommt ihr diesen Film?
Es kommt darauf an, was der Mix ist am Ende. Es gibt 5 plus 1, wie heißt das auch in Deutsch? 5 plus 1 ist Surround. Oder Stereo, je nachdem. Bei Surround hast du dann mehr Spuren, weil du den ganzen Effekte und die Musik brauchst du ja auch in Surround. Und dann tippst du die Originalversion, um dich zu orientieren natürlich. Sowohl beim Dubbing als auch beim Mix willst du ja nachher, dass das so ähnlich klingt wie die Originalversion.
Genau, aber ihr bekommt Sprache und Musik und Soundeffekte separat. Genau. Wie separat ist das dann alles?
Das kommt immer darauf an, wie gut die das vorbereitet haben, auch wie die das beim Dreh hingekriegt haben mit der Aufnahme. Da gibt es riesen Unterschiede. Es gibt Soundtracks, nicht Soundtracks, also Musik und Effekte heißt das M&E, Tracks. Die sind komplett, da ist alles drauf. Da sind Ambiente in jedem Restaurant, alles ist drauf. Zum Beispiel bei so Menschenmassen, wenn du in eine Bar reingehst, kannst du im Hintergrund nicht unterscheiden, welche Sprache die sprechen. Und das kann man dann verwerten für alle möglichen.
Okay, verstehe.
Dann machst du nur die zwei Protagonisten, die vorne im Bild sitzen und die setzt du dann da oben drauf. Aber es ist ganz unterschiedlich von der Qualität hier. Manchmal musst du da ganz wenig machen, manchmal musst du den Tag lang um die Ohren schlagen und irgendwelche Ambientes machen, wenn du zum Beispiel... Da gibt es ein Wort für, ich weiß es nicht, aber ihr versteht mich schon.
Ambiente denke ich mal, ist ein universell verständliches Wort. Ich verstehe dich auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist auch wieder ein Thema für sich. Weil zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Riesen-Menschen-Menge hast, holst du natürlich nicht eine Riesen-Menschen-Menge ins Studio, um diese Riesen-Menschen-Menge zu machen, sondern dann hast du vielleicht drei Leute stehen und die machen dann zehnmal übereinander dasselbe, irgendwie in verschiedenen Stimmen, um diese Menge zu kreieren. Genau. Das hängt aber ziemlich vom Kunden ab, wie gut die da vorbereitet sind.
Das heißt, ihr schaut euch den Film aber vorher auch das Material vorher mal an, bevor da irgendwie die Preise gemacht werden?
Wir gucken uns meistens nur das Drehbuch an. Das Drehbuch und dann guckt man, wie viele Leute da ungefähr drin vorkommen und wie viel die reden. Du kannst einen 90-Minuten-Film mit fünf Seiten Drehbuch haben, der dann natürlich sehr billig ausfällt. Oder du kannst eins haben, was 60, 70 Seiten hat.
Ja klar, das ist ja ein Unterschied, ob man jetzt so einen landschaftsschwangeren Kurosawa-Film hat, wo man die ganze Zeit nur in die Weite staut oder so ein Woody Allen, wo einfach die ganze Zeit nur gequatscht wird.
An der Hand vom Drehbuch macht man dann den Kostenvoranschlag. Und wenn man sich dann einig geworden ist, dann bekommt man das ganze Material. Dann guckt man es sich natürlich erstmal an. Also ich sozusagen in meinem Fall, für Deutsch. Dann entscheide ich, wer wohl am besten dieses Drehbuch hinkriegt. Das ist ja auch immer ein bisschen...
Da muss man den Film ja aber auch richtig verstehen, oder?
Wäre nicht schlecht.
Fällt einem das nicht manchmal schwer? Ich bin schon auch ein paar Mal aus dem Kino gegangen, da haben wir so was... haben nichts verstanden. Aber vielleicht muss man ja auch gar nichts mehr verstehen.
Mein letzter Film, den wir gemacht haben, das war ein tibetanischer Film, vom tibetanischen ins deutsche. Ich hatte den tibetanischen Originalfilm mit einem französischen Drehbuch dazu. Dann habe ich mir diesen Film angeguckt und hab mit dem Drehbuch in der Hand versucht zu verstehen, wer wann wo was sagt. Aber die Sprache ist so komisch, da kannst du nicht mal, wenn du den Text führst, also das Satz, da steht zum Beispiel, ich bin hungrig und dann sagt er den Namen von ihr. Dann versuchst du den zu verstehen, während die da sprechen und du kannst nicht mehr den Namen raushören. Also manchmal versteht man auch nicht wirklich.
Das heißt, die Filme kommen eigentlich auch aus allen erdenklichen Sprachen und jetzt nicht nur so aus den paar Sprachen, mit denen ihr euch sowieso beschäftigt.
Die tibetanischen Filme bekommen wir nicht oft. Zwei oder drei im Jahr vielleicht. Aber die meisten sind englisch oder spanisch, leider. Das ist natürlich auch sehr schwierig, dieses tibetanische ins deutsche zu übersetzen, kulturell. Aber egal, wir wollten erst mal weitermachen, wie das abläuft. Dann schicke ich das Drehbuch zu Übersetzen. Das sind eigentlich zwei Schritte. Ich rede jetzt von Spielfilmen. Dann gibt es erst mal einen, der übersetzt nur dieses Drehbuch aus der Sprache, in der es kommt, in deine, ins deutsche. Aber der übersetzt eigentlich auch ohne Bild. Der muss den Film auch nicht gesehen haben, der muss auch nicht wirklich verstehen, worum es geht, sondern der macht ganz wörtlich, also nee, nicht wörtlich, Quatsch, aber bildunabhängig eine Übersetzung. Eine korrekte Übersetzung. Und dann schickt man das wieder zu jemandem, der das Synchrombuch schreibt. Und einerseits guckt er auf die Lippenbewegungen, passt diesen Text an die Lippen an, wenn du die Lippen aufmachst, ein A, eine O, die Vokale.
Verstehe, das sind sozusagen zwei Schritte. Man übersetzt erst mal und dann macht man eine Übersetzung auf den Film quasi.
Und die besteht hauptsächlich daraus, das an die Lippen anzupassen und auch, das nennt man, zu lokalisieren. Lokalisieren ist also kulturell zu lokalisieren.
Die Sachen mit dem Spülmittel und dem Geschirr.
Genau. Wie dann auch sozial zum Beispiel. In welcher sozialen Schicht spielt der Film? Reden die prollig miteinander? Oder sind die gebildete Leute? In welcher Zeit spielt das?
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt werden so Flüche dann schon übersetzt? Schon im ersten Schritt?
Im ersten und dann im zweiten wieder rausgeschnürt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass solche bestimmte Flüche dann schon gar nicht mehr als solche erkennbar sind, wenn man sie wörtlich ins Deutsche übersetzt. Soweit ich mit spanischen Flüchen vertraut bin.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die sind einfach nicht übersetzbar. Und die gibt es einfach nicht in anderen Sprachen. Das ist schwierig, was ich finde. Die Amerikaner sagen immer Fuck. Da kannst du nicht immer Fick sagen.
Ich.
Oder verflucht, keine Ahnung.
Das klingt aber dann auch komisch.
Ja, nee, verflucht nicht. Oder du lässt es einfach weg, weil das geht nicht. Das sind so kulturelle Sachen, die kannst du nicht übersetzen.
Ja, das Sexuelle und das Fäkale lässt sich immer nicht so ohne Weiteres verbinden. Das stimmt.
Da gibt es große...
Man flucht wahrscheinlich dann auch wirklich zu anderen Zeitpunkten.
Ja, zum Beispiel in Spanisch gibt es herrlich viele Flüche, die man eigentlich... Deutsch ist ziemlich schwierig zum Fluchen. Auf Deutsch ist es schwierig.
Verflucht.
Ich will auch schon zuhören.
Ja, das geht nicht irgendwie.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist ja das, was ich meine. Da gibt es ja diese sexuelle Fluchsprache, die halt im Englischen, auch im Spanischen der Fall ist. Da wird halt die ganze Zeit irgendwie gefickt und gebumst und irgendwie durchgenommen und was nicht alles. Und ich kenne mich aus. Ich war mal in Mexiko, da wird viel geflucht. Und hier ist halt immer alles scheiße.
Ja, also hier ist es, es macht keiner. Das macht man nicht. Man spricht einfach keine Flüche. So im Normalen Leben. Verdammt sagt auch keiner. Nicht wirklich.
Na ja, vielleicht schon, wenn man irgendwie sich, keine Ahnung, verschrieben hat oder so.
Aber wirklich, ja, genau, da stößt man auch an die Grenzen der kulturellen Übersetzung.
Aber trotzdem, es gibt diesen zweigeteilten Prozess. Es wird erst mal übersetzt und dann wird auf den Film übersetzt und kulturell übersetzt.
Das zweite ist die größte Herausforderung. Das ist auch sehr kreativ. Du spielst sozusagen mit dem Satz. Du hast deinen englischen Satz. Die Satzstellung im Englischen ist aber immer anders als im Deutschen. Das heißt, erst mal übersetzt den so und dann ist er erst mal zu lang auf Deutsch. Punkt eins, er ist immer zu lang, wenn es beim Englischen ins Deutsche geht. Dann fängst du an, zum Beispiel musst du...
Moment, macht ihr eigentlich auch Untertitel? Ja.
Machen wir auch, ja.
Das heißt, dieser selbe Prozess kann dann auch unter Umständen, dann geht man sozusagen von der Übersetzung noch mal in eine Untertitelübersetzung.
Das sind aber eigentlich zwei getrennte Sachen. Ist dir noch nie aufgefallen, wenn in einem Film, du siehst ihn gedarbt und du guckst dazu, die Untertitel in der selben Sprache, ist es nicht dasselbe oft, ne?
Ja.
Ist dir schon aufgefallen?
Das ist mir schon aufgefallen.
Genau, weil das zwei verschiedene Leute machen normalerweise.
Aber ist das dann so, wenn man Untertitel macht, übersetzt man das so gleich vom Drehbuch in die Untertitel oder macht man auch diesen zweistufigen Prozess?
Nee, direkt vom Drehbuch. Aber Untertitel haben andere Anforderungen, wir dürfen nur so umso viel falschen sagen. Genau, wir waren beim Synchrombuch. Ja, das ist eine große Herausforderung, weil du einerseits korrekt übersetzen musst, du musst die ganze Information bewahren, wenn es geht, was nicht immer klappt, du musst manchmal auch etwas rausnehmen an Informationen, weil es einfach nicht reinpasst. Du musst überlegen, okay, welche kann ich jetzt aus dem Kontext, was kann ich hier weglassen in dem Satz? Was passiert einem ganz oft, wenn man aus dem Englischen kommt, weil das Englische sehr viel prägnanter und kürzer ist als das Deutsche. Und außerdem handelt es sich um Dialoge, das heißt, die Dialoge müssen fließen, das ist nicht wie eine Buchübersetzung, sondern das sind Dialoge, das sind alles Dialoge und die müssen ineinander fließen. Das ist eine ganz andere Art von Übersetzung. Und das ist halt sehr spielerisch. Man arbeitet viel mit Synonymwörterbüchern im Internet. Wenn das Wort nicht passt, guckst du die zehn Synonyme, die es dafür gibt, ob eins davon passt. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann stellst du den Satz um, dann baust du den andersherum. Das ist wie ein Spiel mit den Wörtern, dass es irgendwann passt. Aber es darf natürlich auch nicht so gestellts klingen. Man kann es auch nicht konstruieren wie mit einem Baukasten. Es ist eine sehr kreative und sehr spannende Form von Übersetzung. Erweiterte Form von Übersetzung.
Und dann, wenn sozusagen dieses zweite Drehbuch dann steht, dann muss es dann aber auch wirklich gesprochen werden.
Genau, dann hat er meistens das Synchrombuch geschrieben. Da führt er meistens auch die Regie. Weil er kennt den Film dann sehr gut. Und er weiß, wie er sich genau das mit dem Text gedacht hat, wie er da drauf muss und so. Deswegen ist es meistens dieselbe Person, die dann auch Regie führt.
Also in dem Fall dann du. Und muss man dann für jeden einzelnen Schauspieler, der in so einem Film auftaucht, auch eine Synchron-Stimme haben? Oder wird dann auch mal... Hätt ich nicht fragen sollen, oder?
Eigentlich kommt drauf an, ja. Wenn das Budget groß genug ist, kann man eine für jeden, aber das merkt keiner. Wenn du am Anfang irgendwie eine Stimme hast und die benutzt am Ende noch mal für eine kleine...
Ja, irgendjemand auf der Straße, la la la...
Also es ist sowieso ziemlich schwierig, Stimmen wiederzuerkennen, meistens. Wenn man da nicht wirklich drauf achtet, nach fünf Minuten hast du vergessen, wie der da vorne klang. Also natürlich den Hauptdarsteller kannst du nicht doppelt besetzen, den Hauptdarsteller und dann noch einen. Aber diese ganzen Nebenfiguren, wenn man da wirklich mal drauf achtet, da gibt es schon einige, die sich wiederholen.
Das ist auch die Frage, wie gut man sich selber da verstellen kann und verschiedene Charaktere raus schicken kann aus seiner Stimme.
Ja, das ist bei Spielfilmen so schwierig. Das hörst du schon, wenn jemand seine Stimme verstellt meistens. Bei Zeichentrink natürlich ganz was anderes, aber bei Spielfilmen ist es ein bisschen... Nee, macht man eigentlich nicht. Ihre Stimme verstellt, das hört man.
Ich verstehe jetzt meine Stimme auch nicht.
Genau, und wir machen...
Regie.
Wir gehen jetzt ins Aufnahmestudio.
Erstmal musst du ja diese Leute auch finden. Du musst ja dann im Prinzip jede einzelne Person dir einmal anhören, also vermute ich jetzt mal, achtest du dann auch darauf, dass du jemanden findest, der so klingt? Oder ist es eigentlich nur Mann, Frau und es muss passen?
In unserem Fall, da wir in Spanien sind, haben wir natürlich nicht so viele Sprecher. Also ein Studio in Berlin, der hat vielleicht 250 oder 300 Stimmen zur Verfügung von ausgebildeten Schauspielern, die alle das können. Aber wir haben natürlich nicht so viele. Wir haben zum Beispiel vielleicht ungefähr 40, die gut sind.
Das sind aber auch alles Schauspieler, oder wie?
In der Regel schon, aber es gibt auch ein paar Ausnahmen. Es gibt auch Leute, die das wirklich...
Die nur synchron machen.
Nee, es gibt Leute, die haben so einen Naturtalent, die stellst du vor das Mikro und es geht. Das sind zwar die wenigsten natürlich. Oder Leute mit Radioerfahrung oder Podcast-Erfahrung.
Okay, ich seh schon, wer das hier mal nicht läuft, der laden. Kann ich noch sowas machen.
Auf jeden Fall hätte ich da was zu tun, finde ich. Die Technik, die das synchronisieren, das kann man lernen. Wenn jemand expressiv ist und seine Stimme gut kennt, kann man auch Synchronsprecher werden, ohne eine Schauspielausbildung zu haben. Du kannst natürlich dann nicht alle Rollen sprechen. Weil dann deine persönlichen, deine psychologischen Einschränkungen, die schränken dich dann auch beim Spielen ein. Deswegen muss ich bei Leuten, die keine professionelle Schauspieler sind, also meistens sind es, aber manche nicht, die haben eine schöne Stimme, die können meistens nur sich selbst spielen. Die können spielen, oder naja, nicht nur sich selbst.
So wie sie selber so drauf sind, meinst du?
Genau, zum Beispiel, da merkst du ganz klar, wo die Grenzen von den Leuten sind. Wenn du einen Film hast, wo viel gelacht wird zum Beispiel. Es gibt Leute, die können nicht lachen. Es gibt Leute, die können zumindest auf Befehl so nicht lachen. Oder es gibt Leute, denen fällt das wiederum total einfach. Die können aber nicht böse werden. Weil jetzt kommt eine Szene, wo du jemanden anschreien musst und die können das nicht. Und das lernst du natürlich als Schauspieler. Als Schauspieler lernst du, das ganze Spektrum abzudecken. Wenn du mit Halbprofis da arbeitest, musst du halt die psychologisch auch sehr gut kennen. Aber da wir nicht so viele haben, kenne ich die natürlich alle sehr gut. Und ich weiß genau, wo die ihre Stärken haben, wo die ihre Schwächen haben, wie weit die gehen können, wie weit die schreien können und so.
Wie viele Stimmen hat denn so der durchschnittliche Film?
Zwischen zwei Stimmen, zum Beispiel Antichrist, zu 30, 25, 30.
Okay, da habe ich mir noch nie darüber Gedanken gemacht, mit wie vielen Personen man es eigentlich wirklich zu tun hat, normalerweise. Klar, es gibt natürlich ein paar Filme, da weiß man, da sind es einfach extrem wenig.
Ich würde mal sagen, im Durchschnitt zwischen 15 und 25.
Tatsächlich, gleich so viel. Ja, wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, was weiß ich, so ein normaler Hollywood-Action-Movie, wo dann so die zwei, drei Hauptdarsteller irgendwie durch die Gegend ballern, und dann lassen sie sich hier nochmal mit dem Kommissar unterhalten und da nochmal mit dem Zeugen und dem Zuträger und dem Grandoven und dem Drogendealer und so, da kommt natürlich ein bisschen was zusammen. Aber ob es jetzt irgendwie 50 oder 20 sind, hätte ich jetzt so aus dem Gefühl heraus gar nicht sagen können.
Nee, eher 20 als 50. Aber diese psychologische Dinge, das ist wirklich sehr spannend. Kannst du selber über dich viel auch herausfinden, wenn du plötzlich vor diesem Mikro stehst und weinen sollst oder schreien oder böse oder fies werden oder liebevoll. Und jeder hat da so seine Grenzen. Also außer den Schauspielern natürlich. Obwohl die auch, gar nicht wahr, die können auch nicht alles.
Aber das stimmt schon. Also ich meine, ich mache ja in der Regel immer nur dialogische Podcasts, aber wenn ich mal was alleine spreche, dann denkt man auf einmal ganz anders darüber nach, welchen Ausdruck man jetzt eigentlich in seine Stimme hineinpacken will. Die Situation, das quasi nicht vorschreibt. Und ja, da sind glaube ich auch viele dann auch schon mal schnell beim fünften Versuch. Weil sie irgendwie nicht so richtig wissen, wie sie sich jetzt eigentlich einordnen sollen.
Und es ist mir auch schon passiert, dass wir Sachen aufnahmen, unterbrochen haben und es ging nicht. Wir waren jetzt beim Casting stehen geblieben.
Da muss man auch Mut zum Stopp haben. Genau, das heißt du hast so deinen Pool von Leuten. Das sind dann irgendwie so alle deutsche Schauspieler, die da irgendwie Barcelona am Strand rumhängen und so. Die habt ihr euch dann so in den Zeitraum eingesammelt. Und könnt ihr dann irgendwie anrufen und sagen, hier, neuer Film, komm mal rum.
Genau, komm mal übermorgen rein. Ich brauche dir für drei Stunden. Und dann quetsche ich die aus drei Stunden. Emotional und in Niederhinsicht.
Wir müssen aber eigentlich so viel vom Film gar nicht wissen.
Ich erzähle dir am Anfang die Synopsis vom Film.
Worum es geht.
Genau, ich erkläre den so ein bisschen wie der Charakter auf einer Person ist, den sie sprechen natürlich. Das ist schon wichtig, klar.
Da gibt es dann wahrscheinlich auch Filme, wo es schwieriger ist, das zu vermitteln. Was weiß ich, wenn ich mir jetzt so französische Beziehungsmonzetten da, ja, was weiß ich hier, so Eric Romer oder solche bedeutungsschwangeren Filmchen, da ist es bestimmt ganz schön schwierig, überhaupt mal zusammengefasst zu bekommen, wie die alle so drauf sind.
Ja, und man hat auch einen gewissen Freiraum als Sprecher. Man muss ja nicht unbedingt genau imitieren, wie der das macht im Original. Du kannst auch dieselben Gefühle auf eine andere Art...
Und die hören sich das dann schon auch an, wie das im Original ist, was sie dann sprechen sollen. Oder gibt es auch Leute, die dir sagen, das will ich gar nicht hören?
So, da sag ich aber klar, du hörst ja das an.
Ja, okay, gut, das ist dir schon wichtig, dass man sich das anhört.
Also ich erkläre denen, worum es geht. Dann gehen wir ins Studio, es geht los. Es gibt einen Techniker, der darauf achtet, dass alles gut klingt. Du brauchst natürlich ein sehr gutes Mikro und du brauchst einen sehr neutralen Raum, damit du nachher die Szene in jegliche Umgebung versetzen kannst. Wenn der Raum nach irgendwas klingt, bist du nachher nicht mehr frei beim Mixen. Wenn du zum Beispiel hörst, dass es ein kleiner Raum ist und nachher steht der im Film auf einer riesigen Ebene, das kannst du nicht mehr kitten im Mix. Also der Raum muss natürlich sehr, sehr neutral klingen.
Und dann geht's los.
Dann guckst du dir mal das Original an. Einmal, zweimal, je nachdem, wie schnell der Schauspieler ist. Und los geht's, dann wird gesprochen. Und in Deutschland sitzt noch eine Person im Raum, die nur darauf achtet, dass es in den Mund passt. Also, dass der Satz, den du aufgenommen hast, auf den Film passt.
Nur in Deutschland?
In Deutschland ist das so. Bei uns in Spanien, in unserem Studio, ist es nicht so. Da macht das der Techniker sozusagen zusammen mit dem Regisseur. Die achten auch darauf, dass das passt.
Okay, es wird getan, aber es ist jetzt nicht noch mal eine extra Person.
Genau, genau. Und in Deutschland wird aber vom, wie heißt das, Synchronenverband Deutschland, wurde aber vorgeschrieben, dass diese dritte Person auch noch mit im Raum ist.
Was ist denn deren Berufsbezeichnung, bitte schön?
Äh, Editor heißen die.
Editor, ach so, ich dachte, das sind jetzt so Lippensynchronisationskontrollörer oder sowas. Mich nicht wundern, wie du so was bist.
Ja, genau, Editor heißen die. Und die gucken sozusagen, selbst wenn es in dem Moment nicht passt, aber die sagen, wenn man das ein bisschen verschiebt nach da und da, passt das nachher. Und die sagen eigentlich die ganze Zeit wenig und dann nur ab und zu sagen, stopp, passt nicht, nochmal. Und dann wird auch mal der Text ein bisschen geändert. Es kommt natürlich vor, dass es dann doch nicht klappt, wie man sich das ausgedacht hat vorher im Synchrombuch. Dann nimmt man, okay, wir sind jetzt beim Aufnehmen, der Regisseur sagt, ob die Trabanturgie stimmt, ob ihm das gefallen hat, ob das von der Intention gepasst hat. Wenn ja, geht es weiter, nächster Take. Sonst macht man halt verschiedene Aufnahmen. Und so wird einer nach dem anderen aufgenommen, auch nicht zusammen. Ab und zu, wenn sich durch den ganzen Film die beiden Hauptdarsteller sich immer unterhalten machen, nimmt man auch mal zwei zusammen auf.
Ach so, aber üblicherweise auch so ein Dialog wird überhaupt nicht als Dialog aufgenommen?
Nee, nee, nee. Das sind alles Overdubs. Einer fängt an, dann kommt der nächste und so fühlt sich der Film langsam.
Echt? Und das funktioniert?
Das wusstest du gar nicht.
Das erklärt unter Umständen auch so das eine oder andere. Aber ich würde ja mal so in meiner leihenhaften Betrachtung von außen meinen, dass man doch ganz anders spricht, wenn man auf jemanden eingeht in dem Moment. Ich kann doch nicht irgendwie eine Antwort liefern, wenn ich nicht weiß, wie die Frage gestellt wurde. Ist das vielleicht einer der Gründe, warum das so manchmal so merkwürdig wirkt?
Aber es geht halt schneller, wenn man die nacheinander macht. Wenn du zusammen aufnimmst und der eine packt den Satz genau dahin, wo der muss, der andere steigt ein bisschen zu spät ein, die überlappen sich, boah, muss das ganze Ding nochmal machen. Das dauert länger.
Das ist sozusagen für die Montage einfacher.
Man macht das manchmal mit zwei zusammen, aber das ist auch das höchste der Gefühle. Mal zwei zusammen.
Das ist eigentlich ein lonely job. Man sitzt da irgendwie so alleine in seiner Tonkammer und hat dann irgendwie so seinen Text und dann muss man das irgendwie so runtersprechen. Aber man hat sich schon vorher mal die Situation angeschaut.
Wie ich gleich am Anfang gesagt hab, ich bin nicht so ganz glücklich, wie das ist mit dem Dubbing und mit dem Stellenwert, den es hat.
Ja, und wenn du das jetzt anders machen könntest, dann würdest du das zum Beispiel anders machen?
Unter anderem würde ich mehr Dialoge zusammen aufnehmen. Aber dafür braucht man mehr Zeit. Die Studios, es geht ja um Geld. Ein Studio ist teuer pro Stunde. Deswegen ist das sehr, sehr maschinell. Läuft das ab. Der Sprecher kommt rein, fünf Takes, los, schnell, fertig, schon gut, Nächster. Also es ist nicht... Und eigentlich ist der Dabben wie Schauspiel, nur ohne Kamera. Und beim Schauspielen würde das keiner so machen. Wenn die ihren Film aufnehmen, sagt keiner jetzt beeil dich, aber mal irgendwie, ja, ist schon gut, passt. Aber nachher machst du die Synchronversion und da ist es dann so, passt schon, komm, Nächster. Und dabei müsste man eigentlich beim Dabben genau die selbe Liebe und das selbe Herzblut da reinstecken wie beim Schauspiel. Das ist dasselbe. Und du kannst mit einer lieblosen Synchronisation den Film zerstören, so einfach ist das.
Definitiv. Gibt es nicht auch dann Produzenten oder Verleiher, die sagen, bei diesem Film ist es uns jetzt besonders wichtig, dass der besonders gut...
Viel zu wenig, viel zu wenig. Also selbst wenn wir uns reingehängt haben, wie die irren und dann den Film dahingeschickt haben und dann Feedback wollten wir vom Kunden, schwer zu kriegen. Aber ganz wenig. Ich glaube, das wird total unterschätzt. Total unterschätzt. Wenn der Film fertig ist, dann ist die Arbeit vorbei. Ist ja überhaupt nicht. Es wird wirklich, wirklich vernachlässigt. Sowohl von den Produzenten. Wenn ich meinen eigenen Film produzieren würde, würde ich mich damit ins Studio setzen. Und sagen, nee, das gefällt mir nicht. Oder wirklich zumindest die Stimme aussuchen. Oder zumindest mal den Regisseur, anrufen und gucken, ob der verstanden hat, was ich mit dem Film sagen will. Und das wird auch viel zu wenig. Also man kriegt ganz, ganz wenig Feedback von den Kunden.
Gibt es nicht auch Filme, wo auch die Schauspieler verschiedene Sprachen sprechen? Und wo der Film dann am Ende sozusagen überhaupt erst durch so eine Synchronisation dann fertiggestellt wird, überhaupt in seine Originalversion versetzt wird?
Das gibt es auf jeden Fall. Zum Beispiel, warte mal, der letzte, äh nicht der letzte, der...
Wie ist das mit Arnold Schwarzenegger? Den haben sie einfach mal sprechen lassen, ne? Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, es sind so einige Deutsche, die irgendwie in Amerika produzieren.
Die werden schon geduppt in der Originalversion, ja. Na ja, also es gibt unterschiedliche Sachen. Zum Beispiel auf der anderen Seite von Fatih, der Film, der ist teilweise in Türkisch, Kurdisch gedreht.
Von Fatih, Akin.
Genau, auf der anderen Seite spielt ja teilweise...
Deutscher Regisseur. Kennt ihr noch alle oder nicht? Ich muss zu meiner Schande gestehen, dass ich noch keine Gelegenheit hatte, mir mal so die gloriosen Filme anzuschauen. Aber ich bin eh in den letzten Jahren fast nicht ins Kino gekommen. Ich hab mir jetzt gerade mal Avatar angeguckt, nach irgendwie x Jahren war ich mal wieder im Kino. Ja, so ist es mit Kindern.
Kannst du doch aus dem Internet runterladen und dann zu Hause...
Naja, auch die Zeit hat man ja selten. Da bin ich dann aber auch wieder so eigen, dass Filme, die ich toll finde, die will ich dann auch erleben. Das funktioniert dann immer nicht so richtig und dann bringe ich es aber auch nicht aus über das Herz, mir sie dann irgendwie nur so auf 3,5 Zoll anzuschauen.
Aber am Ende siehst du sie dann überhaupt nicht.
Ja, na zumindest habe ich dann nicht gesündigt. Gefühlsache. Aber jetzt erzähl, was du meinst als Beispiel. Muss ich ja nicht gesehen haben.
Der ist halb auf türkisch.
Welchen Film meinst du jetzt?
Auf der anderen Seite mit Hanna Schigule. Der letzte, der vorletzte, weiß nicht genau.
Bekannt war dieser gegen die Wand, den ich auch nicht gesehen habe.
Solltet ihr alle sehen, das ist toll. Der ist zum Beispiel halb auf türkisch oder kurdisch gedreht oder beides und auf deutsch. Wenn er jetzt ins Kino kommt, dann macht man halt die türkischen und die kurdischen Stellen mit Untertiteln. Aber dann fürs Fernsehen zum Beispiel nicht. Es gibt im deutschen Fernsehen praktisch keine Untertitel außer auf Arte oder auf Dreisat. Und die Leute sind auch nicht dran gewöhnt und keiner will Untertitel sehen. Und wenn man über 60 ist und schlecht sieht, dann sieht man die sowieso nicht auf dem kleinen Bildschirm. Deswegen werden dann solche Stellen auch ins Deutsche gedapft, die Fernsehversion zumindest. Und dann gibt es auch Fälle, wo zum Beispiel ein Spanier in Hollywood spielt und schlechtes Englisch spricht. Der wird dann von Anfang an sowieso gedapft. Witzigerweise, wenn die Schauspieler sich manchmal, also Javier Bardem zum Beispiel macht einen Film auf Englisch und der soll sich dann dabben in Spanisch. Das geht ganz oft schief. Die können sich selbst nicht richtig dabben, die Schauspieler. Frag mich nicht, wieso, das ist ein komisches Phänomen.
Sich selber zu sprechen, das ist komisch. Die sollen es tun. Sie tun es dann auch oder sie lassen es dann, weil es nicht klappt?
Das kann man nicht, komischerweise. Das erwähne ich jetzt nur so am Rande, weil ich das kurios finde. Es klappt oft nicht, dass sie sich selber synchronisieren im Nachhinein. Das klingt dann nicht gut. Das klingt besser, wenn es ein Synchromessprecher macht. Ich weiß nicht, wieso.
Komische Welt. Aber ich meine, das ist ja auch ein bisschen doof für den Schauspieler, weil ja doch, glaube ich, dann die Zuschauer, die Native-Viewer natürlich die Stimme schon auch erkennen.
Nein, für uns ist die Synchrom-Spräche, die Kosynchron-Stimme von Javier Bardem, ist für uns seine Stimme. Wir sind so dran gewöhnt, wir kennen die original Stimme nicht und für uns spielt das auch keine Rolle.
Aber wenn der mal einen Film dann auf Spanisch macht, also der spricht Spanisch oder ist das jetzt so? Okay, wenn der jetzt mal einen Film macht, der nur auf Spanisch ist, wird er dann auch noch synchronisiert und er taucht mit seiner eigenen Stimme nie auf.
Doch, nee, nee, dann ist er natürlich schon mit seiner eigenen Stimme, klar.
Ja, aber das ist doch absurd, dass du mal denselben siehst, in Spanisch mal hat da jemandes andere Stimme und mal seine eigene, also mal so, mal so. Das ist doch verwirrend. Vielleicht ist es so, das ist dann halt einfach verwirrend.
Ich glaub schon. Es gibt auch diese festen Stimmen von den berühmten Sprechern, sind auch nicht immer dieselben.
Also...
Geht ja auch nicht immer, manchmal sterben die ja dann auch ein bisschen früher.
Zum Beispiel, oder die wollen zu viel Geld haben, dann nehmen sie jemand anderen. Wenn man so guckt, also viele von den berühmten Schauspielern haben zwei, drei Stimmen, die jeder... Der eine hat zehn Filme gemacht, der andere fünf und der dritte sieben. Ich glaube, oft werden die dann auch zu... Das ist nämlich auch so eine Verhandlungssache, in Deutschland zumindest, dass die Sprecher sagen, wie viel Geld sie wollen, wenn die eine feste Stimme sind, wenn die berühmt sind.
Ich erinnere mich gerade nicht ausreichend, aber es gab irgendwann mal so auch eine Serie von Spielfilmen, wo das dann irgendwie eine feste Stimme war. Und dann ist der, weiß ich nicht, ob der gestorben ist oder ob der dann auch zu viel Geld haben wollte. Auf jeden Fall hatte dann dieser Schauspieler auf einmal eine andere Stimme und es war nicht zu ertragen. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob das James Bond war oder so. Naja, so ein typischer, so wie James Bond, zwar ist es glaube ich nicht James Bond, aber wo irgendwie so jemand, der so bekannt war, dass immer wieder mal einen Spielfilm rauskam oder vielleicht eben auch so eine Serie, ich weiß nicht, was, Harrison Ford? Oder war es irgendwie in Star Wars?
Das kann auf jeden Fall ganz schön schockieren sein, wenn die Stimme ändert von dem Schauspieler, in dem du dein ganzes Leben gewöhnt bist auf jeden Fall. Okay, wir haben jetzt unsere Sprecher aufgenommen, einen nach dem anderen. Sie sind da jetzt alle drauf, das ist ein großes Patchwork, im Pro Tools wird das größtenteils aufgenommen. Da haben wir jetzt das ganze Stückchen, dieses große Mosaik zusammengesetzt und hoffen, dass das jetzt alles passt mit den Dialogen, auch wenn wir die Stück für Stück aufgenommen haben. Weil natürlich, wenn du einen Teil von dem Dialog aufgenommen hast und dann kommt der nächste, der mit dem spricht, dann hört der den anderen Deutschen, der schon gesprochen hat. Klar, und da kann man dann schon darauf achten, dass der Dialog dann funktioniert.
Okay, verstehe, es gibt einen, der der erste ist, aber man spricht sozusagen immer gegen das, soweit es schon synchronisiert ist.
Genau, und dafür ist der Regisseur ja auch da, damit er diese Linie sieht, damit er diese Vision hat, wie das Ganze am Ende klingen muss.
Du stehst dann auch so mit so einer Klappe irgendwie?
Nein. Mit der Peiche stehe ich da.
Oder mit Räucherstäbchen, die nach dem betanischen Film habe ich versucht, das Studio zu ambientieren. Hab dann das Licht gedimmt und Räucherstäbchen auch angesündet.
Hat das geholfen?
Ja, weil die reden da alle so langsam an dem Film. Ich hatte so eine Klangschale da.
Ich sehe schon. Du bist engagiert.
Ja, man, da kann man echt noch was machen beim Dubbing. Da ist wirklich noch Spielraum und wir haben irgendwie alle ein gutes Dubbing verdient. Wir können noch nicht irgendwie die Qualität von den Filmen, die schlechtere Qualität von den Filmen sehen, weil die Stimmen nicht richtig gemacht sind. Das haben wir nicht verdient. Wir wollen ein richtiges Dubbing hören. Und es muss nicht zwingendermaßen gruselig sein, die Filme gedubbt anzugucken. Es ist durchaus möglich, das zu machen, damit man wirklich den Film auch in der Synchronfassung genießen kann. Das ist möglich. Man muss halt wirklich dasselbe Herzblut reinstecken, wie beim Drehen.
Kennst du denn Beispiele? Kennst du so Filme, die, was weiß ich, in Deutschland ins Kino gekommen sind, wo du sagen würdest, wo du auch das Original kennst oder wo du es einfach vom Zuschauen her empfinden kannst? Das war gut. Fällt dir da irgendwas ein? Ich meine, du bist jetzt nicht in Deutschland, von daher. Also du bist ja jetzt auch deshalb nur hier. Das kann man auch nochmal erwähnen, weil jetzt gerade Berlinale läuft in Berlin. Das ist ja dann sozusagen hier dein Umschlagplatz. Hier läuft alles im Original. Also zur Berlinale läuft alles im Original. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer denn da Untertitel gemacht hat.
Untertitel auf Englisch, normalerweise alles auf Englisch. Genau, und wenn das dann erst dann verkauft wird, wird die Synchronfassung gemacht. Jetzt ich überlege gerade mit dem Film, was man jetzt als gutes Dubbing so, gibt es natürlich, aber ich kann es jetzt nicht so sagen.
Da fällt uns noch was ein.
Aber jeder kennt glaube ich gute und schlechte Beispiele und kann sich nicht daran erinnern, was diese Beispiele nun eigentlich sind.
Ich glaube es geht wirklich. Ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass man das so machen kann, dass es nicht gruselig ist, das ausgedabt zu sehen. Und wirklich, ich gucke fast alles im Original. Und dann mache ich auch zwischendurch, schalte ich immer um. Ich habe an meiner Fernbedienung so einen Knopf, wo man die Sprache einfach so umschalten kann. Habt ihr vielleicht auch, müsst ihr mal ausprobieren, wenn ihr eine DVD anguckt zum Beispiel. Einfach zwischendurch mal in die verschiedenen Sprachen zu schalten.
Die AB-Taste.
Einfach mal zwischendurch die verschiedenen Sprachen angucken. Da fällt man manchmal aus allen Wolken. Genau, wir kommen jetzt nämlich zum Mix. Der Mix ist nochmal so ein anderes Thema.
Ja, das ist nämlich auch etwas, was mir aufgefallen ist. Da geht häufig was schief. Also du hast zwar vielleicht das ordentlich gesprochen, aber in dem Moment, wo ich mir die synchronen... Also da hab ich nämlich genau dieses Experiment gemacht, was du so sagst, nicht wahr? Da lief dann mal auf Arte tatsächlich mal ein Zwei-Kanal-Ton. Das gibt es ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Da wird einfach viel zu wenig genutzt. Läuft das mal so und dann schaltet man irgendwie hin und her oder man macht es auf einer DVD und stellt dann irgendwie fest, die komplette Atmo, die komplette, wie sagst du so schön, die Ambience? Die Ambience ist dann so, dass man die Ambulanz rufen möchte. Es klingt dann auf einmal wie aus einem trockenen Raum.
Ja, das ist ganz seltsam. Also zum Beispiel im Spanischen, bei spanischen Synchronisationen wird das im Mix anders gemixt. Der Originalton, also die Hintergrundgeräusche, die sind ganz weit hinten und die Dialoge sind ganz weit vorne. Wie im Theater. Vorne stehen zwei Leute und haben einen Dialog und irgendwo im Hintergrund fährt ein Auto vorbei. Im Original ist es oft nicht so, sondern es ist richtig eingebettet in diese ganzen Soundeffekte. Aber da macht jedes Land so ein bisschen auch, was es will. Im Deutschen ist die Mischung ein bisschen besser. Da achte man mehr darauf, dass es so ähnlich ist wie im Original.
Gibt es andere Länder, bei denen es explizit eher gewünscht ist, dass es alles ineinander aufgeht? Wenn du sagst, im Spanischen ist es so.
So viele Länder kenne ich jetzt auch nicht. Aber ich kann ganz gute Spanische und das Deutsche vergleichen, weil ich da arbeite. Die Spanier, denen ist es egal, wie die Originalversionen ist. Die ignorieren die einfach und machen das, wie die meinen, wie das sein müsste. Die sind auch vom Dubbing her ganz anders. Die sind so theatralisch, übertriebene Emotionen.
Und die ganzen Frauen haben eine ganz hysterische, hohe Stimme, wie dass du die Krise kriegst. Die Männer haben eine ganz tiefe Stimme.
Wie heißt dieser eine Schauspieler? Der hässliche, der immer bei den Brüdern Conan mitspielt?
Steve Buscemi.
Geiler Schauspieler. Auf jeden Fall, der hat eine ganz hohe Stimme. Aber in Spanien hat er auch heute so eine Stimme. Die Spanier machen auf alles tiefe, brummelige Bärenstimmen. Finden die gut.
Zumindest ist mir auch schon mal aufgefallen, dass das dann überhaupt nicht passt. Ja, komisch, dabei ist das ja gerade so ein Merkmal. Aber es ist natürlich dann auch super schwierig, da jemanden zu finden, oder? Der dann irgendwie auch, das weiß ich, finden wir erstmal jemanden, der dann so hochspricht.
Ach, die gibt's schon. Die Leute gewöhnen sich an irgendwas und dann machen sie das immer weiter und hinterfragen das nicht mehr, ob das wirklich so sein sollte oder nicht. Das ist alles Gewöhnungssache. Man gewöhnt sich an das Dubbing, wie das ist, und so bleibt das dann. Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Ist egal. Ich frag dich noch auf jeden Fall was. Wir ziehen ja hier die Diskussion entlang der Produktion. Dann kommen wir wieder auf interessante Ideen und Nebenkriegsschauplätze. Jetzt wolltest du ja noch mal zum Mix vielleicht ein bisschen was sagen, wie ihr das normalerweise, wenn es so läuft, wie du es gerne hättest.
Wir haben jetzt die ganzen Sprecher aufgenommen. Wir haben das editiert nochmal. Man geht natürlich nachher nochmal drüber, editiert das schön, damit es auch wirklich in den Mund passt und staucht das ein bisschen, zieht das ein bisschen auseinander. Bei Produktion ist das ja ganz einfach. Und dann geht es in den Mix, wo jetzt die Stimmen zusammengelegt werden mit den Soundeffekten und der Musik. Man orientiert sich an der Originalversion und versucht das so ähnlich zu machen wie die Originalversion im besten Fall. Was natürlich nie klappt, weil schon allein der Raum klingt anders, das Mikro klingt anders, es wird nie gleich klingen, keine Chance.
Das Mikro klingt anders? Mit was für Mikrofonen nimmt der da auf, wenn ich da mal so fragen darf als Podcast?
Bei uns sind alles Neumann U87.
Also fettes Zeug aus Berlin.
Großmembran Kondensatoren auf jeden Fall. Kann aber auch eine andere sein, muss nicht unbedingt ein altes Neumann sein.
Ist das ein altes Neumann?
Die gibt es auch, Neumann.
Aber Neumann, das ist so das, was auch in Radiostudios bevorzugt rumsteht, zumindest hier im Berliner Umfeld. Das ist eigentlich so die Bude, die so die Mikrofone TM macht. Ich habe keins, muss ich dazu sagen. Das ist nur ein AKG, Großmembran Mikrofone, was viel zu selten zum Einsatz kommt. Und naja, hier habe ich zwar jetzt in den Hatsets auch Kondensatormikrofone, aber das kann ich nicht. Klingt ganz gut. Ich bin auch ganz zufrieden. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein guter Kompromiss.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt in den Mix. Wir sind fertig mit dem Mix schon? Nein, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Bist du schon fertig?
Na ja, ich meine, man macht dann halt den Mix. Okay, gut, dann sind halt die Stimmen mit dem ganzen Soundtrack und mit den Aktionsgeräuschen und so weiter verheiratet. Ist es dann schon fertig? Das war's.
Eigentlich schon. Genau, dann überspielst du das noch auf das entsprechende Medium, zum Beispiel die G-Bit-A-Senden.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder, was mir vorhin auch eingefallen ist. Gute Beispiele in Synchronisation, wobei jetzt nicht so sehr im Vergleich zum Original, und ich hab das auch noch nicht überprüft, aber es war so, dass es gab mal im deutschen Fernsehen die synchronisierte Fassung eines, so eine Fernsehserie, die war auch mit, Gott, jetzt muss ich erst mal nachdenken. Ich glaube, die hieß Die Zwei.
Ja, ich weiß, wovon redest du. Das ist ein berühmter Fall.
War das Roger Moore?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich schlag es nochmal nach.
Aber die Geschichte habe ich schon oft gehört, nämlich diese Serie hat wohl aufgrund der Synchronisation so viel Erfolg gehabt.
Genau, im Original, ich schlag es gerade mal vor, genau, es kam aus Britannien und hieß im Original The Persuaders. Im Deutschen halt einfach nur die zwei. Und war eigentlich so, so sagt man immer, im Original gar nicht so ein Erfolg. Aber in Deutschland hat es total eingehauen, weil die halt einfach so viel Humor da reingespielt haben. Das will man ja gar nicht glauben, ja. In Deutschland Humor.
Die haben auch was gemacht, was man eigentlich nicht so machen kann im Dubbing. Die haben das Original missachtet, ne? Das Original gibt dir ja eigentlich diesen Rahmen, in dem du dich bewegen kannst. Du kannst versuchen, diesen Rahmen so weit aufzufüllen, wie es geht, aber du darfst eigentlich nicht über den Rahmen drüber hinaus, das erweitern oder in eine andere Richtung führen. Das macht man eigentlich nicht. Das darf man nicht. Aber die haben wohl gesehen, dass das Ding Potenzial hatte, mehr als das, was die eigenen Produzenten gesehen haben. Und haben das gemacht. Das war glaube ich auch eine sehr große Kontroverse.
Das heißt, da war sozusagen die kulturelle Übersetzung im Vordergrund?
Die haben nicht. Die haben wirklich die Dialoge abgeändert. Die sind da richtig weit gegangen.
Das heißt, sie haben eigentlich etwas ganz anderes daraus gemacht?
Die haben sich da sehr viel Freiheit genommen. Ich hab's nicht gesehen. Ich kann's nicht vergleichen. Aber ich weiß, dass das ein Präzedenzfall war, dass die da wirklich was Außergewöhnliches gemacht haben. Das hat sich nämlich überall rumgesprochen.
Ja, die Alwissene Müllhalde hat tatsächlich auch... Okay, das Ding war sozusagen in fast allen Ländern, insbesondere in den USA, kein Erfolg. Nur halt in Deutschland ein großer. Und diese ganze Flapsig- und Witzigkeit kam in Deutschland sozusagen überhaupt erst dazu. Hände hoch, ich bin ein Axel-Fetischist. Sleep well in your Bettgestell. Ja, interessant. Also das zeigt sozusagen, wie viel man da auch kulturell eigentlich vernichten oder eben auch hinzufügen kann, wenn man denn nur gelassen wird. Ja, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Fernsehserien, die es around the world geschafft haben, so. Das beste deutsche Beispiel ist, glaube ich, immer Derrick. Das ist, glaube ich, so die meist synchronisierte Fernsehserie überhaupt. Insbesondere in China, glaube ich, auch total. Da habe ich jetzt keine Einblicke, wie das dann so synchronisiert wurde, aber es wirkt schon irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, der, der Chinesisch redet?
Ich habe es mal gesehen, ich kann es mir nicht wirklich vorstellen, aber so war es. Irgendwie sind die Chinesen da total darauf abgefahren auf diese merkwürdige deutsche 70er Jahre Atmosphäre. Ja, es ist schon irgendwie verrückt.
Da muss man auch wirklich von Fall zu Fall entscheiden, wie man diese Filme transportiert aus einem Land und andere. Da gibt es auch kein Konzept für, kein Vorgehen, wie man das jetzt immer machen könnte. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Man muss wirklich von Film zu Film entscheiden, wie man das macht, wie man den platziert, wie man das macht, damit die Leute ihn einerseits verstehen. Ich will auch nicht dieses exotische Nehmen, was der Film hat. Ich denke oft dran, als Kind hat mir meine Mutter Zwergnase vorgelesen. Zwergnase fand ich super exotisch, aber das hat mich nicht geschreckt, sondern das hat mich nur bereichert. Also diese Kindergeschichten, 1000 in eine Nacht, wo du irgendwie verstehst die Worte eigentlich nicht. Es gibt ganz viele Worte, die du nicht verstehst. Du verstehst die Leute überhaupt nicht, was die machen, aber es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Es bereichert dich einfach nur.
Der Maharaja.
Es gibt dir ein Gefühl von irgendwas, was du was geheimnisvoll... Das ist eine Bereicherung, es ist egal, ob du es verstehst oder nicht. Und das kann man beim Film auch machen. Man kann auch Sachen lassen, die die Leute eigentlich nicht verstehen. Sondern die tragen nur dazu bei, so etwas Geheimnisvolles zu kreieren, was mysteriöses ist. Da muss man immer von Fall zu Fall entscheiden, wie weit man das jetzt übersetzt, was man drin lässt, zum Beispiel die exotischen Namen zu lassen. Oder was heißt es, sich den Tonfall ein bisschen seltsam zu machen, ein bisschen sich anzupassen. Wenn du einen japanischen Manga oder so ins Deutsche machst, die reden ja alle so hysterisch.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch so ganz konkrete Sprachen. Also gerade bei Derek in China, also Doppel R glaube ich.
Die haben den bestimmt einen anderen Namen gegeben.
Ja, ob der dann Delik hieß oder so, ich weiß es nicht. Aber mit dem Ton haben sie echt ihre Probleme.
Mit dem Namen ist es aber auch sehr schwierig. Ich hatte zum Beispiel diesen tibetischen, das muss ich ja ganz kurz am Rand erzählen, das war nämlich sehr lustig, dieser tibetanische Film. Die hatten natürlich alle tibetanische Namen auch. Ich hatte diese Dialogliste mit diesen Namen. Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, wie man das jetzt aussprechen soll. Aber man kann die auch nicht Peter, Klaus und Hans nennen.
Wie hießen die denn?
Die hießen zum Beispiel Jigundurungatje oder wie hieß die überhaupt da stehen? Die hieß Kargien. Aber da schreibt man zum Beispiel Kargien. Aber ausgesprochen wurde es dann nur Kargien. Und dann habe ich wirklich noch kurz bevor wir aufgenommen haben, mit einer Tibetologin telefoniert, ungefähr zwei Stunden, die mir zwei Stunden lang gezeigt hat, wie man diese Namen ausspricht. Und ich habe immer wiederholt und sie meinten nein, nein, nein, so und so. Und wir haben wirklich zwei Stunden geübt, die Namen auszusprechen. Das war auch dann nachher beim Aufnehmen einer der größten Probleme.
Das heißt, ihr habt die dann auch belassen?
Wir haben die Namen so gelassen. Ich wollte den Film, dieses exotische, nicht nehmen, weil das ist eigentlich so ein typischer Film gewesen, den man niemals dammen sollte, weil er einfach diese Kultur zu sehen, wie die leben. Und dafür ist ja auch Teil der Sprache. Das muss man einfach im Original sehen. Aber egal, deutsches Kino, der war fürs deutsche Kino sogar, der kommt jetzt irgendwann ins Kino. Der heißt Milarepa, der Film.
Milarepa.
Milarepa, ja. Es musste gedappt werden, selbst der Kunde wollte es eigentlich auch nicht, aber es muss halt fürs deutsche Kino, muss halt gedappt werden. Aber wir haben den sehr nah, so nah wie möglich am Original gelassen. Auch die ganzen Ambientes, diese ganzen Märkte und alles haben wir einfach auf tibetanisch gelassen und dann nur obendrauf eine deutsche Stimme gesetzt.
Wie viele Stimmen?
Also was weiß ich, wenn da vorne halt ein Dialog ist, aber wir haben die ganzen, man hört im Hintergrund, dass die anderen nicht deutsch sprechen, sondern wir haben das nicht alles eingedeutscht.
Hast du in dem Film auch eine Stimme mit dabei?
Ne, in dem nicht. Da gab es fast keine Frauen.
Aber du machst das auch?
Ich mach das auch. Warte mal, jetzt hab ich immer noch... Genau, und die Namen, mit den Namen, das muss ich noch fertig erzählen.
Ja, okay.
Das war dann auch eines der größten Probleme, weil du musst den Namen ja nicht nur korrekt aussprechen, sondern du musst den auch noch so sprechen, als würdest du den jeden Tag sagen. Nicht nur unter Folzler Konzentration, sondern es muss auch noch leger und lässig klingen, als würdest du das andauernd sagen. Schöner Film übrigens. Was wolltest du gerade sagen?
Ich warte nur darauf, dass du jetzt alle Aspekte, die du aus dieser Geschichte herausziehen wolltest, auch geliefert hast, um einen neuen Aspekt aufzubringen.
Der Film ist echt ein Thema für sich auch. Tibetanisch besteht aus lauter offenen Lauten. Die machen den Mund beim Sprechen eigentlich fast nie zu. Wenn die zehn Silben sagen, haben wir drei Silben drauf gemacht. Also das ganze Synchrombuch haben wir ja geschrieben blind.
Das heißt, der Mund bewegt sich eigentlich auch gar nicht.
Genau, die Formen mit der Kehle da hinten, diese Laute. Und wir haben das Synchrombuch blind geschrieben. Wir haben den Ton ausgemacht, haben nur auf das Bild geguckt. Weil man konnte sich überhaupt nicht orientieren an dem, was die da gesprochen haben.
Damit es dann wie deutsch aussieht, dann darf man dann sozusagen nur Worte mit A und Os nehmen.
Schaut ihn euch an, ich bin auf und für alle Kommentare auch.
Du hast ja darüber gesprochen, wenn man das kann, kann man auch verschiedene Stimmungen machen und so. Du bist ja jetzt eigentlich auch keine Schauspielerin, hast ja auch keine entsprechende Ausbildung genossen. Oder bist du jetzt einfach so ein Naturtalent oder machst du das halt auch nicht? Wenn geheult wird, bist du nicht dabei oder wenn gelacht wird, bist du nicht dabei.
Also ich habe Mikroerfahrung und das hilft mir natürlich schon. Und ich habe natürlich das Glück gehabt, weil ich da arbeite, konnte ich mir viel Zeit lassen, mich da reinzuarbeiten. Und habe dann nach und nach auch diese fehlenden Gefühle erschlossen, die ich vielleicht am Anfang nicht so gut ausdrücken konnte. Und witzigerweise für mich persönlich hat mir das sogar geholfen. Ich habe zum Beispiel gelernt, vor dem Mikro richtig sauer zu werden und richtig loszubrüllen. Das hat mir in meinem Privatleben sogar geholfen. Du weißt ja, wenn du dein Gesicht zu einem Lachen verziehst, dann werden auch die entsprechenden Interveni in deinem Körper schon ausgeschüttet, selbst wenn du nicht lachst. Und ich denke mir, das ist beim Schreien genauso. Selbst wenn du schreist, obwohl du noch gar nicht richtig dabei bist, funktioniert es trotzdem. Ich habe Glück gehabt, weil ich mich ja langsam rantassen konnte. Ich habe mir am Anfang ganz kleine Rollen gegeben, wenn irgendwo eine Frau einen Satz sagt und habe so angefangen. Aber ich komme natürlich aus der Musik und ich komme vom Singen. Deswegen habe ich schon eine Prädisposition, mich vor dem Mikro auszudrücken. Und auch Gefühle vor dem Mikro auszudrücken, was ja unter anderem auch Frauen sehr viel leichter fehlen als Männer. Ich kann nur sagen, wenn wir Castings machen, dann kommen mal 30 Frauen und fünf Männer. Und von den fünf Männern sind vier schon von vorneherein zu steif, um ihre Gefühle, um vor dem Mikro zu weinen. Zum Beispiel, stell dir mal vor, kannst du das?
Ich bin ja kein Schauspieler, ich bin ja immer so wie ich bin. Ich bin halt immer fröhlich. Keine Ahnung, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also, Männern fällt das generell sehr viel schwerer. Wenn sie keine Profis sind, ne? Jetzt mal wieder abgesehen davon. Wenn sie Schauspieler sind, lernen sie das aber. Aber wenn man mit Halbprofessionellen da arbeitet, auch und zu tun hat, hat man immer sehr, sehr viel mehr Frauenstimmen zur Verfügung als Männerstimmen. Ja, und mir hat das mit der Zeit, hab ich mich da reingetastet und hab angefangen, verschiedene Stimmen zu Proben auch wirklich geübt, zum Beispiel für Zeichentrick, wenn du eine Zeichentrick-Stimme machst. Jeder kann mal irgendwie einen Satz mit einer verstellten Stimme sprechen. Aber das Ding ist, diese Stimme dann auch zu halten. Und wenn diese Figur, die du sprichst in der Zeichentrick-Serie, anfängt, verschiedene Situationen zu leben und du musst dann Angst, Schreck, Freude ausdrücken, da kommst du an deine Grenzen mit einer verstellten Stimme. Das muss man wirklich üben.
Wie verstellt ist sie denn dann?
Da kann jeder rumspielen und sich die Stimme ausdenken, wie er will. Manche machen eine ganz hohe, eine ganz piepsige, was auch immer. Das findet man dann so raus. Aber deine normale Stimme, meine geht jetzt von hier bis hier bis hier. Und wenn ich eine Zeichentrick-Stimme spreche, dann ist die zum Beispiel sehr viel höher und sehr viel kleiner und sehr viel weicher. Und dann muss ich den Raum, den diese Stimme nach oben und nach unten haben darf, ausloten. Aber dann mit den verschiedenen Gefühlen. Das ist schwierig, so eine Stimme zu halten über eine ganze Serie oder einen ganzen Animationsfilm, eineinhalb Stunden. Weil die alle möglichen Gefühle lebt und du darfst halt immer nur in die Stimme...
Du nimmst das ja auch über mehrere Tage auf. Du musst ja dann wieder in die Zeit reinkommen.
Genau, dann hörst du dich mal kurz, kommst da wieder rein. Mir hat mal ein Schauspieler erklärt, wie der das macht. Und zwar meinte der, das ist eine körperliche Erinnerung, wo diese Stimme sitzt. Der Körper erinnert sich, wie er diese Stimme platzierte im Kehlkopf. Der war halt ein Schauspieler, der hat mir das mal so erklärt. Ich kann das noch nicht so. Ich habe halt eine verstellte Stimme, die ich halten kann.
Also du hast genau eine Zeichentrickstimme. Das war so eine etwa, die wir gerade gehört haben.
Das ist immer so schwierig. Ohne Text fällt mir das schwer. Ich bin ja auch ein bisschen schüchtern.
Nach Originalrezept hergestellt durch Fermentation natürlicher Rohstoffe.
Also ich mache oft so kleine Mädchen in Filmen.
Biologisches Erfrischungsgetränk. Bionade, Kräuter.
Genau, dann kann man natürlich auch noch ein bisschen mit der Technik da was machen und die noch ein bisschen höher pitchen oder ein bisschen tiefer. Die typische Micky-Maus-Stimme ist natürlich zweieinhalb Töne nach oben gepitcht.
Das ist furchtbar. Muss das eigentlich immer so sein bei Kindern? Warum muss denn immer alles so hochstimmig sein? Geht das überhaupt in die richtige Richtung?
Ich glaube, das färbt sogar auf die Kinder ab. Die reden dann am Ende aus, weil die immer diese piepsigen Zeichendrehstimmen hören.
Aber muss das sein?
Denken sie, das muss so sein als Kind. Nee, nee, ich wusste es nicht. Das ist auch wieder eine kulturelle Geschichte.
In Spanien z.B. werden alle kleinen Kinder in Filmen von Frauen gesprochen und die sprechen dann immer so.
Irgendwie, wirklich, in Spielfilmen, die Kinder sprechen so, ohne Scheiß.
Biologisches Erfrischungsgetränk, Kräuter, Mama, kann ich bitte noch einen Kakao haben?
Die sprechen alle so, das sind nie Kinder. Das muss man sich mal anhören, das klingt gruselig. Aber wie macht ihr das? Wir haben auch Kinder, ja. Bei uns ist es jetzt natürlich, wir in Spanien hier anders. In Deutschland gibt es richtig Kinder-Schauspieler, Kinder-Synchron-Sprecher, die professionelle Synchronsprecher sind, mit sieben Jahren oder so. Und die haben einen vollen Kalender.
Weil die sehr gefragt sind.
Ja, gibt es natürlich nicht so viele, aber es gibt richtig professionelle Kinder-Synchron-Sprecher. Ja, die haben bestimmt... Ja, klar. Das sind glaube ich meistens Kinder von Eltern, die auch Synchronsprecher sind oder Schauspieler. Es gibt auch ganz strenge Auflagen. Die dürfen nur 30 Tage im Jahr arbeiten. Und wenn es dann mehr sind als 30 Tage, dann brauchst du einen psychologischen Betreuer für diese Kinder, der mit ins Studio geht. Das ist ganz, ganz schwierig. Das ist dann auch sehr teuer. Die Kinder sind natürlich langsamer. Und die können nicht so viele Stunden arbeiten.
Ja, das ist ja auch verständlich.
Also ich arbeite witzigerweise in Spanien mit der Theater AG von der Deutschen Schule. Weißt du, es gibt eine deutsche Schule in Barcelona. Und der Theaterlehrer von denen ist einer von meinen Sprechern. Und der hat mir dann seine Talente da ausgelotet.
Verstehe.
Und die bilde ich auch nach und nach so ein bisschen aus. Ja, ich bringe denen das gerade bei. Also es kommt nicht oft vor, dass Kinder sind. Aber ich will denen. Die müssen natürlich bereit sein, wenn dann der Film kommt, wo das Kind in der Hauptrolle spricht, muss einem fertig sein.
Das heißt, du bist ja auch schon richtig erzieherisch tätig. Und versuchst die Kids dann...
Ja, die kommen dann zu uns ins Studio. Und dann üben wir mit jedem Einzelnen. Und ich leite die an und gebe ihnen Tipps und sage ihnen, was sie zu Hause üben können.
Was ich auch mal gesehen habe, es gibt ja auch so eine spezielle blinden Synchrolisation. Habt ihr damit auch was zu schaffen? Du weißt, was ich meine? Wo nicht nur gesprochen wird, sondern wo sozusagen auch alles beschrieben wird. Der Mann geht in das Zimmer, die Tür ist halb zu. Von draußen sieht man, wie Autos vorbeifahren.
Das ist das, was man aus Versehen ab und zu mal einschaltet auf der DVD und dann nicht nur Bade versteht.
Genau, das ist ja dann schon so ein bisschen auf dem Weg hin zum Hörspiel. Ist das für dich auch schon mal so ein Thema gewesen?
Hörspiele?
Geht das nicht schon so eine ähnliche? Das ist natürlich schon was anderes.
Das ist ein super interessantes Thema auf jeden Fall. Aber hab ich noch nie gemacht. Aber ich hab neulich mal ein Hörspiel von Nemo gehört. Großartig.
Nemo von dem Pixar-Film?
Genau, von dem Pixar-Film. Das Hörspiel, das ist herrlich. Die haben sich auch sehr viel Freiheit genommen. Die haben nämlich ganz viele verschiedene Dialekte benutzt. Klar, das ist im Film auch so. Hörspiel oder Film, die haben sich sehr viel Freiheit genommen. Sag ich, diese Schildkröten hast du gesehen?
Den Film findet Nemo hier, den hab ich gesehen.
Die Schildkröten sind Amerikaner, die Deutschen mit amerikanischem Akzent sprechen.
Was ist das im Original oder in der Synchronie?
Nein, in der deutschen Fassung. Dann gibt's einen Fisch, der ist ein Schweizer irgendwie. Die haben da sehr, sehr, sehr viel gespielt.
Den hab ich im Kino gesehen. Den hab ich auf Deutsch gesehen.
Hier im Kino bestimmt auf Deutsch. Die haben ganz viel mit Dialekten gespielt.
Bei Zeichentrick-Filmen ist es mir dann auch egal. Da können sie dann auch deutsch sein.
Dann bist du ja auch kein Original in dem Sinne.
Und die Schildkröten waren amerikaner, die amerikanischen?
Und dann gab's noch einen, den Freund von dem, das war ein Schweizer, der hat auch ganz lustige Sachen gesagt.
Das ist ja auch noch ein Problem, wenn jetzt im Original unterschiedliche Dialekte zur Sprache kommen.
Die werden meistens ignoriert.
Das dann auf deutsche Dialekte zu übersetzen, das ginge nicht, oder?
Das würde schon gehen, natürlich. Das wäre total lustig. Aber es ist einfach nicht gang und gäbe. Das wird dann nicht so gemacht.
Man muss ja auch das kulturelle Äquivalent finden. Bei uns sind ja eigentlich...
Genau, zum Beispiel in Texana würdest du dann irgendwie mit einem Schwaben übersetzen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das passt.
Manchmal passt das schon. Oh, manchmal ist es super. Wie hieß dir der eine Film mit William Dafoe? Aquatic Life hieß der? Wer den gesehen hat, erinnert sich 100% nicht. Weil William Dafoe ein Schwabe ist in dem Film.
Und richtig, richtig, richtig schwäbisch. Und das ist so klasse.
Man könnte so viel spielen mit den Dialekten.
Kannst du mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Schaut euch das mal an auf Deutsch. Aquatic Life heißt da, glaube ich. Irgendwas mit Aqua. Man könnte wahnsinnig viel spielen mit den Dialekten. Und im Original wird auch viel damit gespielt. Kommen die aus Texas oder aus dem Süden oder New Orleans. Die sprechen dann auch hier verschiedenen Dialekten. Aber das wird dann in der Synchromfassung meistens nicht bewahrt. Und auch der Kunde verlangt das dann nicht. Und es ist denen auch egal. Und es ist einfach nicht gang und gäbe, das zu machen. Aber es wär sehr schön. Man könnte da echt tierisch viel rausholen. Das gibt ja dem Film schon an sich eine ganz bestimmte Stimmung. Wenn du dann jemanden hast, der einen leichten Akzent hat.
Das stimmt. Ja, jetzt haben wir eine Menge darüber gesprochen, wie so deine aktuelle Arbeit aussieht. Was bei mir sonst eigentlich immer so ein bisschen der Klassiker ist, dass man auch noch mal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte eintaucht. Das ist jetzt vielleicht schon ein bisschen zu spät dafür. Aber seit wann wird denn das eigentlich gemacht? Schon immer? Ist das so eine moderne Sportart?
Guck mal schnell nach.
Ich weiß nicht, aber hast du da irgendwie so einen Einblick, wie sich das so entwickelt hat? Oder war das schon immer?
Ich hab mal eine tolle Geschichte gelesen über die Anfänge des Dubbings. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr in welchem Jahr. Das war mein Gedächtnis, das ist wirklich für solche Sachen nicht geeignet. Aber es macht ja auch nichts. Auf jeden Fall, was früher gang und gäbe, ganz am Anfang, als die Synchronisation angefangen hat, die Kulissen von dem Originalfilm nachzubauen, damit die Schauspieler sich richtig in diese Rolle versetzen konnten. Und die haben teilweise in diesen großen, nicht Dubbingstudios, wie wir sie jetzt kennen, diese kleinen Räume mit dem Mikro, sondern richtige Aufnahmestudios gehabt, haben da diese Kulissen von den Filmen nachgebaut und sind dann den Sprechern, die die Synchromfassung gesprochen haben, hinterhergelaufen mit diesen Angeln, wie jetzt beim richtigen Film. Und die haben alles nachgespielt. Die sind gelaufen wie die Schauspieler. Die haben den Film sozusagen studiert und haben das dann nachgespielt, der deutsche Sprecher. Das waren glaube ich die allerersten. Ich weiß nicht genau, welche Filme das waren, aber haben sie auch nach sehr kurzer Zeit auch gelassen, weil es natürlich viel zu viel Aufwand war. Aber nur, um zu zeigen, was für einen Stellenwert es hatte und was es haben sollte, das Dubbing.
Ja Trillian, jetzt haben wir es eigentlich, oder? Das war ein interessanter Einblick.
Ja, es war sehr schön, hier beide zu sein, Tim.
Super. Mit welchem Film kann man denn deine Stimme hören, der hier so läuft oder laufen wird?
Wir machen im Moment hauptsächlich Zeichentrickfilme. Also wenn ihr eine Kids-Choro habt, könnt ihr da gerne mal reinhören. Aber das ist nicht so einfach.
Also nur dein alter Ego und deine zweite Stimme sozusagen.
Ja, warte mal, dass wir überlegen. Ja, am besten... Nee, das ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt, das Thema für mich, weil wir oft für Studios arbeiten, die uns... Wir arbeiten in deren Namen sozusagen, weil es immer noch nicht akzeptiert ist, ins deutsche Stubbing im Ausland zu machen.
Verstehe.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht mehr sagen, wir haben das oder das gemacht, weil das unter dem Namen von jemand anderem läuft. Es ist einfach noch nicht akzeptiert, dass es im Ausland auch gehen kann.
Also müssen die Leute dich jetzt sozusagen an der Stimme wieder erkennen. Das sollte ja so schwierig nicht sein.
Wir verlosen einen Teddybären für den, der mich erkennt.
Genau, finde die Trillie.
Könnt ihr bei Tim abholen.
Gut, ich würde sagen, das war's. Vielen Dank nochmal. Und vielen Dank auch wie immer fürs Zuhören. Und das waren jetzt die ersten 150 Sendungen. Die nächsten 150 Sendungen folgen dann so gleich. Und ich bedanke mich wie immer fürs Dabeisein und fürs Wiedereinschalten.